there is a longtime supporter of the
David Pakman show dating back to at
least 2015 if not 2014 it might be and
over the years he sponsored discounted
memberships and he is doing it again to
really help us get 2018 going in a
serious manner 2018 could be a huge year
for the program 2017 was the biggest
year ever for the show in terms of
audience growth and views on YouTube and
podcast downloads and distribution on
radio and television financially it was
a complex year because of what happened
with YouTube D monetization and losing
our Amazon affiliate revenue as well in
the interests of making 2018 may be the
biggest year for the show on all fronts
rather than just some this longtime
supporter is sponsoring half of 33
yearly memberships wait what do you mean
he's sponsoring half of them what does
that mean that's looking at me very very
confused so let me explain behalf
exactly Pat's already confused with the
numbers what this means is that this
Good Samaritan as I call him has already
paid for 30 dollars of 33 $60
memberships he's already paid for 30
dollars this means that 33 of you can
get a yearly membership merely by paying
the other 30 dollars okay this means
that when you go to david pakman.com
slash membership and sign up for a
yearly $60 membership I give you a
coupon code and you will only pay $30
okay and the amazing thing about this is
that you can keep this discounted price
for as long as you want what do you get
with a membership well you get the bonus
show every single day Pat and I do an
additional show just for our members you
get the commercial free audio feed of
the show you get the commercial free
video feed of the show that means that
instead of watching if you're a YouTube
viewer instead of watching the
individual stories publish every 90
minutes after the show is produced
around 4:30 p.m. Eastern you get the
full one-hour program
as one video just for you as a member
how do you get one of these half-price
memberships now we're talking Turkey
that's a good question
you have to email me okay these are
first-come first-served I have 33 of
these half-price memberships go to our
website david pakman.com click on
contact and just write an email saying
hey David I want one of those half-price
memberships and in the order that the
emails come in and usually these tend to
last two to three days ish or something
like that
in the order that the emails come in I
will send you a coupon code that you can
use to get a membership for half-price
nice little opportunity you get a
hundred percent of the benefits at half
the price